he fell off first class but which you
know Charles Manson's like the most
first I tripped on the way out oh yeah
and we're neighbors we're neighbors now
we're neighbors yeah everybody's out
there yeah pas ma master house with a
giant pink Hummer and I was like oh
they're out it looks like a rap video
has a big like T on the gate live kid
like we have to bring my MTV Cribs I
feel like you I agree you know and
you're mad you're mad he's mad he's mad
can I just I was hurt because he thought
you'd sent you a text and you didn't
respond I'm getting big mobile first of
all it's good you use a calling card for
your phone it's not my problem you're
doing the like Brendon I'll be in the
same room and hole sent me a text it
just like will not go through I'm like
homie pay I think that was just a [ __ ]
block what's going on to get a better
carrier dude t-mobile's pretty big-time
they just took over Verizon to merge is
that rachel has been bullshitting with
fake statistics since I got here I'm
telling you the only person to get a
movie greenlight Holly short I know
where do you do it
no how do you know Verizon just bought
t-mobile because uh t-mobile and Sprint
sprint which is big yeah not Verizon
Wall Street Journal every morning I
don't feel like I even know you burned I
read as a reader he's reading a book a
week now I read a book is that true try
yeah really what kind of book right now
I'm reading chaos Charles Manson yeah
why can't you just get it done once and
it's sticked you always got like keep
doing it like girls who get their lips
done they can't see how to do it the
thing that doesn't dissolve what do you
want them to put in their [ __ ]
concrete metal yeah and how do you know
they keep getting it done what is this
where are these statistics coming from
oh I'm sorry fact-check begin laughs
sorry random statistic Magoo what can
your lips done once and then you're good
for life
it's Botox Botox has a show I don't
think it's Botox Botox in the losing
that freezes lips is filler and filler
does not last for life ask any girl
you've ever dated besides me correct
no so they tell you yes why why wouldn't
they
I just want to make that very clear I
don't want to win you why not doesn't
turn them on it's just not my thing
okay got it share me on it I do by the
way there's not accusing you of this do
you see at all there are a lot of MMA
fighters who are into that I don't think
so
well where do you get your research I
have some friends who are trans and some
very famous MMA fighters have reached
out to it that's good don't care no I've
hiked what you mean like friends were
fun yes there's like the dynamic he's
talking about there's lots of just
friends
a friend group I feel when I'm getting
old before I we used to always make that
joke if I have a friend I'm definitely
want to [ __ ] him as I get older
especially if they're smarter I know how
a joke yeah is that as they're smart
especially they're smarter I have more
friends who are women yeah that I don't
want to sleep yes get older and you're
did you get older you're a fake and
you're when you're 20 when you're 21
you're
so who are your girlfriends there's lots
[Laughter]
that I was trying to build little
mythologies for them I'll have somebody
call no no I'll do some vacations we're
done what we do with our kids let's do
it I'm ready yep I had my friend call me
and offer me yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]